en bref la course folle du pétrole tous
les superlatifs ont été épuisés le prix
du baril a frôlé hier soir à new york
les 124 dollars 123 90 exactement depuis
des années des ingénieurs travaillent
sur des sources d'énergie alternatives
voici la première usine destinée à
exploiter commercialement le courant
sous-marin provoquée par les marées elle
produira de l'électricité pour un
millier de foyers dès cet été
en irlande au portage maryse burgot
laurent des bois c'est un ingénieur
britannique présente avec fierté leur
bébé une sorte de moule incapable de
transformer l'énergie des courants en
électricité et dans ce magnifique bras
de mer de l'irlande du nord
ils ont réussi à se mettre la population
dans la poche
c'est une énergie propre
donc forcément une bonne chose une
énergie stupéfiante dans ce détroit où
les courants atteignent 8 noeuds
pour l'instant les travaux ne sont pas
terminés d'où la présence de cette barge
mais à l'avenir ces fermes de moulins
seront construites en pleine mer et
l'essentiel se passera sous l'eau quand
ses hélices de 16 mètres d'envergure
capteront cet inépuisable mouvement des
océans
nous avons cette ressource disponible et
nous avons des kilomètres de côtes
je crois que notre dépendance importante
à l'égard du pétrole nous oblige à faire
quelque chose en août prochain ce petit
port de 2000 âmes vivra donc une
première mondiale
l'hydrolienne sera fin prête raccordé au
réseau électrique national
elle alimentera mille maisons de quoi
faire la fierté des habitants même si
cet engin gâche un peu le paysage y
compris les jours de brouillard
j'espère qu'à l'avenir les designers les
rendrons un peu plus joli
mais ce n'est pas très grave je pense
qu'on s'habitue rentrer
reste une question quel sera l'impact
sur l'environnement de ces hydroliennes
installé à grande échelle
vont elles perturbé les écosystèmes où
les espèces animales
c'est paisible phoques se blesseront
t-il avec les hélices
pas de réponse pour l'instant même si
l'on sait qu'il n'existe pas d'énergie
parfaite
la grande bretagne est une île ce pays
se voit donc déjà comme une sorte d'art
habitat audit de l'énergie marine les
britanniques pour d'ailleurs les
premiers à investir autant d'argent dans
ce genre d'installation oui en france 1
prenant bref la course folle du pétrole
tous les superlatifs ont été épuisés le
prix du baril a frôlé hier soir à new
york les 124 dollars 123 90 exactement
depuis des années des ingénieurs
travaillent sur des sources d'énergie
alternatives
voici la première usine destinée à
exploiter commercialement le courant
sous-marin provoquée par les marées elle
produira de l'électricité pour un
millier de foyers dès cet été
en irlande reportage maryse burgot
laurent des bois
ces ingénieurs britanniques présente
avec fierté leur bébé une sorte de moule
incapable de transformer l'énergie des
courants en électricité et dans ce
magnifique bras de mer de l'irlande du
nord
ils ont réussi à se mettre la population
dans la poche c'est une énergie propre
donc forcément une bonne chose une
énergie stupéfiante dans ce détroit où
les courants atteignent 8 noeuds pour
l'instant les travaux ne sont pas
terminés d'où la présence de cette barge
mais à l'avenir ces fermes de moulins
seront construites en pleine mer et
l'essentiel se passera sous l'eau quand
ses hélices de 16 mètres d'envergure
capteront cet inépuisable mouvement des
océans
nous avons cette ressource disponible et
nous avons des kilomètres de côtes
je crois que notre dépendance importante
à l'égard du pétrole nous oblige à faire
quelque chose en août prochain ce petit
port de 2000 âmes vivra donc une
première mondiale
l'hydrolienne sera fin prête raccordé au
réseau électrique national
elle alimentera mille maisons de quoi
faire la fierté des habitants même si
cet engin gâche un peu le paysage y
compris les jours de brouillard
j'espère qu'à l'avenir les designers les
rendre moins que plus jolie poule mais
ce n'est pas très grave et je pense
qu'on s'habitue rentrer
reste une question quel sera l'impact
sur l'environnement de ces hydroliennes
installé à grande échelle
vont elles perturbé les écosystèmes où
les espèces animales
c'est paisible phoques se blesseront
t-il avec les hélices pas de réponse
pour l'instant
même si l'on sait qu'il n'existe pas
d'énergie parfaite
la grande bretagne est uni
ce pays se voit donc déjà comme une
sorte d'arabie saoudite de l'énergie
marine les britanniques sont d'ailleurs
les premiers à investir autant d'argent
dans ce genre d'installation oui en
france